what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video we're going to talk about
sauber i'm going to give you the closest
thing we get to her origin in marvel
comics because she doesn't fully have
one but she is at least in the marvel
cinematic universe being referred to as
the israeli captain america first things
first in marvel comics that's never what
she was there's never been a time in the
history of marvel comics that i'm aware
of where sabra had donned the moniker of
being the israeli captain america
there's no weapons plus involved in her
history and for those of you guys who
don't know the significance of weapons
plus we'll talk about that here in a
minute because it's very very important
to understanding why captain america
existed in the first place and why she's
different and really not related in any
capacity to captain america but the
thing about this is that the the closest
we get to her origin is really covered
in only a couple different comics
everything else is just fluff the first
of these is the incredible hulk issue
number 256 by bill madlow and the second
is x-men volume 2 issue number 67
written by scott loddell as part of the
operation zero tolerance story which
we'll also talk about that here in a
second but the overall gist of this is
if we really want to go with like the
cameo she had an incredible hulk issue
number 250 when the silver surfer was on
earth he had basically flown through uh
tel aviv airspace and just kind of
scanned the area and basically revealed
to us as the reader that there is a
superpowered being there named sabra but
in the incredible hulk issue number 256
that's where sabra and the incredible
hulk fight and the way this played out
is that by way of his own story the
incredible hulk had basically shown up
on the shores of tel aviv as the
incredible hulk and essentially sabra
was working as a police officer who was
actually a spy at the time but she was a
police officer who had been stationed
there and when the incredible hulk
showed up and basically started
attacking the place it led to her
calling the police but the military
responded instead now again the reason
why was because there were things going
on with bill mantla's run of the
incredible hulk operation green skin
general talbot different things like
that but in general on a broad scale the
incredible hulk was considered a threat
on the national level in any country he
showed up in so that's usually why when
you see stories like the first
appearance of wolverine and the
incredible hulk when the incredible hulk
showed up in canada basically special
forces were sent to respond wolverine
was considered canada's special project
as part of weapons plus being weapon x
and again we'll talk about that in
relation to captain america here in a
second but the thing about that is the
fight between the two of them was
relatively short-lived in the sense that
almost as soon as she emerged and
announced herself as basically being
sabra the superheroine of the israeli
state that the incredible hulk had
started to morph back into bruce banner
and basically escaped now he ended up
taking off into the city of tel aviv and
then came across a young boy who he
befriended the downside to this is
around the time that happened basically
people busted in they ended up bombing
the place and shooting the place up and
the little kid died and so in response
to that the incredible hulk manifests as
a result of banners anger over the death
of this kid and that draws the attention
of sabra a fight breaks out between the
two of them we're given some display of
her power in the sense that she can
shoot these barbs they basically start
to weaken the incredible hulk this is on
top of all the other powers she has
flight super strength durability in
effect the powers of superman because
those things are given out like candy in
this day and age and so in a weakened
state and realizing that he has to
recover the incredible hulk grabs the
kid and then takes off that's when sabra
follows suit and then when she arrives
at where the incredible hulk landed we
come to the realization she thinks the
incredible hulk killed the kid but when
banner responds or when the incredible
hulk responds and saying i'm not the one
who killed this kid it was actually the
conflict between these warring groups of
people in this part of the world that
led to the death of this kid that
ultimately the incredible hulk takes off
and sauber is just kind of left there to
come to terms with the fact that this
giant war is showing a sort of casualty
now the significance of why that
mattered to her on such a level was not
fully explained until 20 some odd years
later when we got to operation zero
tolerance now operation zero tolerance
was basically just another story marvel
had published at the time which was just
like there's a guy named bastian who
wants to kill the mutant population
because who doesn't in marvel comics and
it just kind of followed that form and
function in relation to sabra we didn't
get a ton of information here but one of
the things that we learned is that at
some point in the past her son was
killed in a terrorist attack hence the
reason why the death of this young kid
and the incredible hulk story had hit
her so hard but the other part of this
origin which is actually given to us in
marvel superheroes vol 2 issue number
six and does have some important
components so we really should cover it
here but this origin basically revealed
that at the early days of her life when
she was a little kid she was moved to a
kibbutz i think it's how you pronounce
it but it was basically an israeli
settlement and this was done partly
because of the fact that she had powers
that had manifested because she was
actually a mutant and really nothing
else now what ended up happening is that
once her powers did manifest she was
rolled into israeli secret service also
known as the massad which was their
version of the weapons plus program now
this is when we start to get into the
nature of like captain america and that
kind of stuff and how she's not exactly
that way so when it comes to captain
america and marvel comics conventional
wisdom and even the original stories
would tell you that captain america was
just an experiment to create a super
soldier by the us government and that
was it and again that's the way it was
originally when grant morrison started
writing the x-men he turned that entire
mythos on its head and for reasons we're
not going to get into here what we ended
up discovering is that captain america
was actually called weapon one that's
what project rebirth was the entire
basis behind steve rogers becoming a
super soldier even though he had no idea
this was the case was to basically
contain and control the mutant threat
kind of the precursor to project wide
awake in marma comics the intention
behind weapon one which was ran by the
overarching weapons plus program is that
captain america going into world war ii
was a field test if he demonstrated the
ability to operate as an effective super
soldier then when the war was over and
he was brought back home his mind would
be wiped he'd be given whatever
programming he was supposed to have been
given and he would go forward operating
on behalf of weapons plus to contain and
control the rising mutant population as
we know he was basically frozen in a
block of ice and was believed to have
been dead so what weapons plus did is
they started focusing on other weapon
projects weapon 2 weapon 3 weapon 4
going all the way up to weapon x also
known as weapon 10 or wolverine and of
course that led to things like deadpool
and emma frost and so on and so forth
but the importance behind this is that
with captain america's project while it
was super top secret it's all stuff that
leaks out because they're intelligence
agencies their job is to literally know
things that are not supposed to be known
and so that's why in russia you had
things like department x you had the red
room right where natasha romanov came
from guys like colossus were basically
being kidnapped by the russian
government and forced into the winter
guard which was their version of a
superhero program but israel was doing
the exact same thing the mossad within
israel had its own version of that and
that's what sabra was rolled into now
unlike russia's department x and like
the red room it wasn't really that dark
per se but the overall gist of this is
that's how she ended up becoming a spy
but following that stuff she basically
kind of graduates into the greater
superhero community she hangs out with
the x-men for a little while does some
stuff but doesn't really do anything
that matters but that's the long and
short of the origin of her character
relatively straightforward and to the
point if you know where to look um but
again one of the things to take away
from this video is that she has not and
is not tied to the captain america
mythos in marvel comics not that i'm
aware of unless something's changed
recently like she's appeared in the
recent captain america comics which
honestly i'm behind on there's nothing
to indicate that's the case i'm not
entirely sure why the marvel cinematic
universe is doing that i'm not really
sure what their motivation is i'm
curious to find out i mean i imagine
they're probably just grabbing
individuals from across the world
slapping the moniker of captain america
on them and basically creating what is
an effect batman incorporated in the
marvel cinematic universe where there's
like a captain america in every country
i don't really know but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace